à la gare de lviv les flots de voyageurs
se croiser il y a ceux qui partent pour
la pologne voisine et ceux qui viennent
à peine de poser leurs bagages et qui
tente de se remettre de leur long
périple à travers l'ukraine
nous venons de passer 24 heures dans le
train il y avait beaucoup de monde mais
tout ça n'a pas d'importance le plus
important c'est que tous les habitants
de marioupol s'ils ont pu monter dans le
transport en vie et en bonne santé
car mario paul continue de vivre sous
des bombardements incessants selon les
autorités locales deux bombes
extrêmement puissante aurait frappé la
ville ce mardi ces images satellite
montrent des immeubles en feu ou
détruits dans la ville elle la procureur
général d'ukraine n'a pas hésité à
parler de génocide dénonçant l'absence
totale de considération pour les civils
à mario paul près de 100000 habitants
serait encore présent et les couloirs
humanitaires n'ont toujours pas été mise
en place selon volodymyr zelensky les
habitants de mario paul n'ont pas de
nourriture pas d'eau pas de médicaments
ils vivent sous les tirs d'autres de
constance où des bombardements constants
depuis plus d'une semaine nous essayons
d'organiser des couloirs humanitaires
fiable pour les habitants de marioupol
et presque toutes nos tentatives
malheureusement sont entravés par les
occupants russe coupable selon kiev
seuls sept mille civils sont parvenus à
fuir la ville mardi